NARRATOR: For the past 20
years, New South Wales averaged
four shark attacks a year.
But in 2009, a
staggering 17 attacks
occurred, with species
ranging from white sharks
to wobbegong sharks.
With such a variety of
species behind the spike,
investigators focus on
something that affects them all.
Marine biologist Holly Richmond
heads out to investigate.
She dives in to
get a closer look.
Shark nets.
First deployed in 1937, they're
at more than 50 public beaches
across New South Wales.
Typically around
200 yards offshore,
these meshings form
an underwater fence
with a simple purpose.
Basically shark nets
they are culling device.
So their aim is to
catch and kill sharks.
NARRATOR: Supporters
of the program
believe that they've
helped keep sharks
away from innocent beachgoers.
But critics contend
there's a harmful downside.
Putting a net in the
ocean, you're going to catch
a variety of different animals.
Rays, dolphins,
whales, sea turtles.
There's been dugongs up North.
There's a variety of
different animals.
Pretty much anything
that's in the ocean
is going to get
tangled in these nets.
And all this
bycatch could have
an unintended side effect
tied to one of shark's
most important senses.
Shark expert,
Doctor Vic Peddemors
cuts in to get a look.
The brain is really
the center point
for all of the
different senses so
that it can detect
food and other
animals in the environment.
NARRATOR: If there's
bycatch stuck in a net,
a shark will use
two of its senses.
Sharks have got a really,
really good sense of smell.
It allows them a
really acute ability
to detect fish, blood, and
unusual smells in the water.
NARRATOR: Additionally,
sharks use
their lateral line
system to detect the prey
item moving in the water.
So bycatch could in fact draw
sharks closer to the nets that
are intended to keep them away.
And in 2009, reports
emerged that holes
had formed in shark
nets similar to those
deployed in New South Wales.
Could sharks, drawn
in by bycatch,
be slipping through
flawed nets and coming
into contact with humans?